>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Pamela Jackson:
Wow, this is exciting.
So good morning.
I'm Pam Jackson.
I am the Director for the Library
of Congress Center for the Book,
and I'd like to welcome
you here this morning,
and thank you very
much for being here.
Welcome you to The
Library of Congress
and to the Coolidge Auditorium,
and I'd like to welcome the staff
and leadership of the National
Campaign to Stop Violence.
I'd like to welcome the students,
the parents, the guardians,
educators, leaders, Department
of Education officials,
Foundation officials
that support the program,
Do the Write Thing,
Challenge program.
To my Library of Congress
colleagues I thank you
for your presence here, as well.
It's an honor to have you all here
and it's a privilege
to be in your midst.
It's a part of our vision here
at The Library of Congress
that we are the chief steward of
the record of knowledge for America
and for the world, thus, creating
a springboard to the future.
And the future that I hope to see
is one of compassion and courage,
one of industry and innovation,
one of remarkable accomplishment
and achievement, one
of peace and harmony.
A part of the Library's
central mission is
to provide the American people with
a rich diverse and enduring source
of knowledge that can be relied
upon to inform, inspire and engage,
and to support intellectual
and creative endeavors.
The future I want to live in is one
where societies thrive and flourish
because we live in
caring communities,
strong, educated, empowered.
We live as individuals contributing
to one another's intellectual
and creative endeavors consistent
with the Library's mission,
a future where we care
about each other's success
and growth and development.
The future I want is
one in which each of us,
every one of us values
human life, honors it,
respects it, cherishes it.
And I'm clear today, we're
here today in this room
because that future has yet to
be fully and completely realized.
We're here today in
this room because some
of us have been hurt and harmed.
Others of us have suffered
and been helpless or silent.
Still others have been the
source of hate and injury.
It may be you or the person next
to you, but really it's all of us.
You all, in particular
the authors of the letters
in this fabulous program and
book, have my deepest appreciation
for your strength and
for your courage.
I'm grateful you're here to share
your stories, to add your writings
to the collections of the
Library and to promote peace.
The Library of Congress
Center for the Book,
which does include the Young
Reader Center and the Poetry
and Literature Center promotes
books and libraries, literacy
and reading, poetry and literature.
And we do so because we know
they are the source and the fuel
for informed and engaged societies
and communities, and we also do
so because we know they are
the absolute best weapons
against intolerance
and against ignorance.
The Center for the Book was
established by Public Law in 1977
and incorporates several
public-private partnerships designed
to implement programs and awards,
such as this one, and we are part
of the National and International
Outreach Division within The Library
of Congress so it's our mission
to nurture and empower the network
of organizations with whom we
partner to strengthen our capacity
to serve communities and to
provide the broadest access
to the vast diverse
and rich collections
of The Library of Congress.
We are proud and completely thrilled
to count the Do the
Write Thing program
as our partner and our friend.
And it's clear from my
reading of these letters
that we can win the battle against
hate and violence and intolerance
because of who you are, your
willingness to shine brightly
and be your best self,
and your willingness
to forgive and have compassion.
So I'm profoundly convinced that
the future that I said I wanted,
that will be, because
you're here today.
Thank you for being here.
[ Applause ]
Now please join me in giving a
very warm welcome to Dan Callister,
Chairman of the National Campaign
to Stop Violence, Chairman
and its Founder I just learned.
Thank you so much.
Please welcome Dan.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Callister: Thank you, Pamela.
It's great that you were
willing to let us come here
and continue our partnership
with the Center for the Book.
I had no idea how eloquent you
are, a very impressive speech.
And I would like to say hello
to an old friend up here.
John, would you just
stand up for one minute?
John has run the Center
for the Book.
[ Applause ]
And been our host at this
event for many years.
Now he's taken over as Historian
for The Library of Congress,
and we wish you well in
this new position, John.
Now it's my opportunity to invite
four of our students to read
from their writings that are
in our book before we make
the official presentation.
The first one is Stormy
Montez [Assumed Spelling],
this is an 8th grade
student from Coastal Bend,
Texas, Fulton Middle School.
Stormy?
[ Applause ]
>> Stormy Montez: I
started from my sleep.
I could hear the roaring
boom in my father's voice,
like a train crashing
down the tracks.
Yelling and hitting, the
screams so loud and vulgar.
I can see him hitting my
mom over and over again.
This wasn't the first
time, they often fought.
This time was different,
my mom was hitting back.
My sister and I watched,
crying and scared.
We didn't know what to do.
When my mom and dad saw us we
were told to return to bed.
In the morning my dad was gone.
We ended up losing
everything and having to move
because the money had
been spent on drugs.
Sadly, I know my father
abused drugs and was abusive,
yet someday I just
want to say I love you.
I wish this was the end
to my miserable story,
but surely things got worse.
I was dreadfully bullied
starting around the third grade,
but began to gain weight and I no
longer looked like the other kids.
It made me a perfect target.
I tried so hard to not
let words get me down.
The fact is I felt worse, like
a burden to everyone around me.
I wanted it to finally stop.
I remembered the words
that my grandpa told me,
looking in my eyes, be strong.
It wasn't long after I
started to bully other kids.
It was interesting how it happened.
I was finally accepted
by the cool kids,
even though I knew they
weren't my friends,
they just enjoyed watching
me get in trouble.
I felt horrible when I bullied
them because I know how it felt.
I understand their
pain all too well.
I had to break the circle.
I needed to work on
myself and needed help.
It was taking a lot of work,
but I am much stronger now.
So why do we behave like this?
Hurting others, ourselves
feel better,
acting violently by
hitting and injuring?
Honestly, there are
countless causes for violence.
Most people do not want
to make poor choices,
but we learn from what has been
modeled, be it positive or negative.
Behaviors from violent video games
or movies in order to reduce,
to prevent acts of violence.
We must work and help people
feel safe, cared and supported,
also helping and develop healthy
sense of self-esteem and self-worth.
I could have become bitter
about what I have been
through, but I'm not.
Instead I've learned to forgive
and I will not be held
hostage by my past.
My slate is clean.
These obstacles have been painful.
Today can show and
use these experiences
to help the next generation
from being harassed and bullied.
Though there may be one
person helping other youth
to see their value, I
personally challenge each of you
to break the cycle and help
influence someone for the better.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Callister: We'd like to
now hear from Brenda Flores.
Brenda is an 8th grader
in Brightwood Education
Campus in Washington, D.C.
[ Applause ]
>> Brenda Flores: Violence
is a word with a big meaning.
Most of the people in this world use
violence to resolve their problems.
When I think of the word violence
the first thing that comes
to my mind is conflict, death,
war, a lot of negative things.
In my opinion it's not necessary to
use violence to resolve a problem.
You can talk and find a
way to solve your problem
without hurting or killing someone.
Violence has affected my
life because I used to live
in El Salvador, now classified
as the most dangerous
country in the whole world.
I couldn't go to school because I
was scared I'd get killed on my way.
I couldn't play outside
because my mom was scared
that I could get kidnapped.
However, violence has
changed my life in a good way.
El Salvador was too dangerous, I had
to immigrate to the United States.
The first day that I got
here I thought it was going
to be really hard on me because
I didn't speak English and I knew
that everything was going to change.
But now that I know the language
I have more opportunities
than in El Salvador.
Because of the violence most of our
parents would be working all day
to give us what we need, but they
don't give us enough time to talk
to them and say what we feel,
what type of friends we
have, who is around us.
From the age 13 to 19 it's
important to get orientation
because at this age we are changing,
we're trying to find who we are.
We should know that if
a person does drugs,
isn't a good person
to be around with us.
We can't be friends with
someone that is part of a gang
because at some point they're going
to tell you you should
join the gang.
If you do this you are going to
get money, you're going to be cool,
everyone is going to respect you.
But we don't think that at the
end you're earning problems.
What I can do to reduce youth
violence is try to help.
What I mean with this is if I
know someone that is doing drugs
or is part of a gang or is
thinking to join these things,
to think really good what they
are going to do or they are doing.
Because doing these things
is like a cycle that goes
over and over and never ends.
And tell them the consequences.
If you do drugs you're going
to feel good at the beginning,
but a few months later you're
going to get addicted to this.
And if you don't have money
you're going to start stealing
so you can get money
to buy the drugs.
And at the end it's going
to end up killing you.
And if you're part of a gang, think,
your family is going
to be in danger.
Why? Because if you don't obey
them they already know everything
about you, and if you run away
your family is going to pay for it.
My advice is that don't let
people influence you or do things
that you don't want to do
because at the end the one
that is getting more hurt is you.
So if you're doing
drugs ask for help,
and if you're in a gang think what
are you doing, and if you feel
like you need to talk to someone
talk with your parents or someone
that is going to tell you
the right thing to do.
Because if you keep doing
this at the end you're going
to get more hurt than what
you're doing right now.
And the consequences are worse
because in this world what
you do is what you get.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Callister: A lot of wisdom
in the words of Stormy and Brenda.
Now Wyatt Ingall [Assumed Spelling],
Wyatt is from the 8th grade
in Austin, Texas, West
Ridge Middle School.
Wyatt?
[ Applause ]
>> Wyatt Ingall: You
said the first prompt is
about how violence has affected my
life, but I'd like to rephrase that,
how hasn't violence
affected my life?
Violence is everywhere and
affects my friends, my thoughts,
and everyone on this planet.
The definition of violence
from Miriam Webster is a great
destructive force or energy.
This implies that violence
falls into the category
of physical violence
and mental violence.
I've been abused mentally
before many times
and so it's almost made me do
some things I know I'd regret.
I've been called an
idiot, a weakling, a retard
and other names I can't remember.
Usually I don't let
these names get to me,
but sometimes it really
affects the way I think.
I know it's stupid that it gets
to me, but I can't help it.
Once I was told I was worthless
and I'd never go anywhere in life.
It really made me think
about suicide.
I planned to kill myself just
because some people thought
it'd be delightful to make fun
of my insecurities relentlessly.
I realize now that I was just being
crazy for thinking that would work
and would be a good solution,
but in that moment I really
wanted to end my own life.
I've learned recently that people
can't hurt me with petty insults
and small stupid assaults anymore,
but if they hurt my friends it feels
as if something has
shoved a knife into my gut.
I wanted to write this
paper because I wanted
to stop seeing good people getting
hurt because of someone else.
I want to see violence removed
from the face of the earth.
But I believe in something
most people don't,
violence can't be stopped,
it can be weakened.
I know that's not the
answer you're looking for,
but I also know why
it can't be stopped.
Human psychology is probably one
of the most fascinating things you
could ever learn about in my opinion
and answers the causes
of violence perfectly.
Humans are social creatures
with complex thinking processes
and a wide variety of emotions,
but it doesn't take a genius
to realize we express some
emotions through violence.
Humans become angry when they
perceive something as a threat
to their mental or physical health.
It's how we've stayed alive,
if you think about it.
Back in the Ice Age we were forced
to kill seal, commit violent acts
at a very young age if
we wanted to stay alive.
Violence can come from history,
genes and all sorts of things,
but there are also animal
instincts and respect.
We humans forget that
we were also animals,
not Godly beings among
other less of all species.
We may fight for territory,
food and other resources
because even though we're
the most of all species
on the planet we're still just
animals who strive to survive.
We also do have some people
who will fight for respect.
Many children thirst for respect,
and those who don't might pay
with it with a few punches.
Now after all those reasons
why we can't solve violence,
I'd like to present a few ways
we can lower the amount of it.
We could easily do what people
are doing now with our schools
and education, but
that'll take generations
of people before it
comes into effect,
which we may not have time for.
I believe that without medicine
we could be more serious
about teaching why violence is
wrong to the smaller children
in preschool and kindergarten.
Children are more impressionable
the younger they are,
which would make teaching
them not to fight much easier
than teaching someone my age.
This would, in turn, make it so
the next generation doesn't fight
as much, but we'll still
have rule breakers and people
with mental illnesses that will beat
down on people or even kill them.
There is no perfect system to end
physical violence, but there can be
for mental violence in my opinion.
Most children if they want to insult
someone will do it over the internet
where a victim cannot
retaliate easily.
This leads to cyber bullying where
people may post private information
about the victim, insult the victim
and even hack the victim's
online accounts to say something
that they would not normally say.
I say we should make cyber
bullying against the law.
Both these ideas would
help solve violence.
The problem is that
we can't solve it all.
Violence can't be stopped, but it
can be less common than it is now.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Callister: Our last reader,
and I hope I pronounce
her name right,
is Ostia Ladonney [Assumed
Spelling], 7th grader,
St. Bernadette Catholic School
in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> Ostia Ladonney: Youth violence,
it's a topic that has
haunted America
for the past few years
and is getting worse.
On the news we constantly hear
about juveniles committing crimes
so serious they are sent to jail
for a big part of their lives.
Every day it seems as if more and
more young adults are making choices
that they will regret in the future.
We have become so accustomed
to hearing about youth violence
that we don't stop and ask
ourselves why youth violence occurs?
First, I would like to
talk about a tragedy
that occurred in my community.
On April 9th, 2014 a
sophomore student ran
through Franklin Regional
High School
with knives and stabbed 21 people.
He was subdued by the assistant
principal and a student
and taken into police custody.
Fortunately, nobody died during
the stabbing, but it shocked
and scared a lot of people.
That incident was the closest
I've ever been to youth violence.
I've seen that in the past
few years security measures
in public buildings, especially
schools, have been tightened.
More security cameras are put up.
Metal detectors have suddenly
appeared in high schools.
Parents became more protective
and many efforts were put
into measures to cease
youth violence.
I think the question we should be
asking is not how can we stop youth
violence, but why does
youth violence occur?
If we know the answer to the
why then we can answer the how.
Youth violence occurs
because of many reasons.
In my opinion the biggest
reason is bullying.
Nonstop harassment from peers does
a lot of scary things to a child.
Fortunately, a lot of people have
seen the disastrous aftermath
of bullying and have started
to alert the public about it.
When a child is harassed over and
over they start becoming depressed.
Some children are bullied
to the extent
that they develop psychological
problems that make them do things
that they would not do otherwise.
Bullying is a big topic that is
a huge cause of youth violence.
We have covered why
youth violence occurs
and now we can discuss
how we can stop it.
The best way to fight youth
violence, in my opinion,
is to talk with your children.
Parents know their own child best.
Spend five to 10 minutes
each day with your children
and ask them how the
school day went.
Tell them to inform you if something
isn't right and they need help.
The connection between parents
and their children will strengthen
over time and will allow them to
feel comfortable discussing violence
and other related issues.
Lastly, parents should monitor what
their children do on technology.
Help your child make safe
choices on social media and talk
to other adults in
your children's lives
that have a strong impact on them.
Most importantly, if you
see your child supporting
or committing violent acts sit down
and gently explain the consequences
that youth violence could
bring to their future.
Tell them that you're proud
of his or her accomplishments
and how youth violence
can harm them.
Find out what caused your child
to support or commit violent acts.
Yelling at them or grounding them
might make them even more determined
to lash out at others.
I hope that you find
my essay enlightening
on the ever broadening
topic of youth violence.
My hope is that using these
strategies less kids are attracted
to committing violent acts
and more people are informed
about youth violence.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Callister: All right,
I'd like to invite the other
three readers to come up
and we'll do the presentation of
the book to The Library of Congress.
So if the other three could come up?
Stormy, Wyatt, and where is she?
Yes, okay, Pamela?
Let's go over here.
[ Pause ]
So this is the official version
[inaudible] and she'll put it
in The Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
Is this one of the
books that got signed?
We also have, Pamela, for you,
this is a collection of the books
and all students have signed it.
[ Applause ]
Okay, now we have - go
ahead and take your seats.
Thank you, Pamela.
We have a special speaker, a man
who has spoken here in the past,
I think we have counted up
today, four or five times
and has become a good friend of
me, of mine, and of our program.
David Esquith, is sitting
over here to my left,
represents the Secretary
of Education.
If I'm correct, David,
we have a new Secretary
of Education now, is that right?
And you can talk a little bit about
the new Secretary if you would?
But David has been a public
servant for most of his life,
started life as a lawyer,
decided to give that up
and actually do something
positive and went into Government,
and has worked in Government
in many capacities.
I forgot to mention when he
was young he was a Peace Corps
volunteer, which gives
you an idea of the type
of personality that David has.
He has five children, but what he
cares about is people with problems
and trying to find innovative ways
to help them solve those
problems through the Government.
He's one of the people I admire
who have put their entire life
into being a public
servant here in Washington,
D.C. And he currently heads the
Office of Safe and Healthy Students.
So David, representing the Secretary
of Education, will speak to us now.
[ Applause ]
>> David Esquith: Good
morning, and thank you, Dan,
and thanks to all of you.
This is one of my favorite events,
and I've read through
all of the writings.
And every year I'm just
incredibly impressed by the honesty
and the thoughtfulness
and the courage that all
of you have exhibited
engaging in this program.
And I really have a lot of
affection for this program,
I think it surfaces
important issues and just
as importantly it surfaces
solutions.
And so I always take a
chance, I prepare a PowerPoint
and I prepare this
before I do the readings.
It's just I try to get it done
a little bit ahead of time,
and I always worry a little bit
when I read through the book
that I've missed the mark, that
there are kind of - there's wisdom
in these writings that I've
missed and that when I present
to you I will - there'll
be a certain dissonance
between what I say and
what you have written.
And I hope this year that I've
- what I say is consistent
with what you've written because
I think you have great insight
into the experience of many
kids around the country.
And so my sincere congratulations
to all of you.
So that's the name
of this presentation.
That's my title.
I do want to correct Dan, I'm not
a lawyer, I was never a lawyer.
I was a Special Education
Teacher and very proud of that,
and have worked in
the educational system
at one level or another all my life.
And not only appreciate the
experience that you all have
as students, but I know there are
a number of parents in the audience
and parents go through school, too.
Every time they have a
kid they go through K
through 12 again and
again and again.
And I do, I've got five
children and five grandchildren,
so I've been through kind of
teenage years myself and I'm going
to go through another round.
And someone told me once and it
just keeps resonating with me
that parents are a
sorry lot, you know?
It's just really hard to be
a good parent all the time.
And I know that you all kind of
appreciate the love and dedication
that you must feel from your
parents, particularly those
who are kind of with
you today on this trip.
So what do I do?
This is the portfolio of the Office
of Safe and Healthy Students,
and I put it up there so that you
can get an idea of kind of the not
so much what my office does, but
the range of issues that kids
in schools are facing these days.
And it is a long list,
it's a complicated list.
So we deal with - and bullying and
cyber bullying is a constant theme
in so many of your writings, but
we also deal with school shootings
and drug abuse, gang
violence, teen dating violence.
My office administers the
Homeless Youth Program,
as well as the Neglected or
Delinquent Youth Program.
We deal with natural disasters,
hurricanes and tornadoes.
The bottom four are things that
are kind of emerging issues
that my office is doing a lot
of work with other agencies,
particularly the FBI, Homeland
Security and the Department
of Justice, on recruitment of
young people by violent extremists,
sextortion, suicide
and human trafficking.
And so I share this list with you to
illustrate just the complex problems
that schools are facing every
day, while at the same time trying
to provide the highest
quality education that they can
to all their students and promote
their academic performance.
Lots of challenges here.
And, as I said, I think some of you
in your writings have really touched
on many of the key variables
that will be our path
forward to deal with this.
So how safe are schools?
And, you know, one of the things
that I - one of the impressions
that you get going through
the writings is that the lives
and the world that you all
experience are very violent
and threatening, and I
certainly kind of recognize
on an individual basis that
that is certainly the case.
But I'm also from the
Department of Education,
so I'm going to inject
a math problem here
to kind of illustrate my point.
So put on your thinking caps
and listen carefully
to the math problem.
A bat and a ball together
cost $1.10.
The bat costs $1.00
more than the ball.
How much does the ball cost?
Raise your hand if you
think you know the answer.
Yes, ma'am?
Nice and loud.
>> Ten cents.
>> David Esquith: Ten cents,
that was kind of the
answer I was looking for,
but it's not the right answer.
And how many of you
thought it was 10 cents,
let's have a quick raise of hands?
So a lot of people, and what you
were doing is you were thinking very
fast, right, you were
thinking very fast.
It seems like the obvious answer, a
bat and a ball together cost $1.10,
the bat costs more than the
ball, it's got to be 10 cents,
seems like the obvious answer.
But what you didn't do was kind
of think statistically
through the problem.
So does anybody now
have the correct answer?
Yes, sir?
[ Inaudible ]
>> David Esquith: I think you've
got the right answer in there.
The answer is the ball
costs a nickel
because if the ball costs a nickel
and the bat costs $1.00 more
than the ball then the
bat would cost $1.05
and together they would
add up to $1.10.
So what's the point?
The point is that despite our
kind of personal experience
in thinking fast we also have
to think statistically and kind
of as you all become
leaders in your communities
and solve problems you have
to kind of move outside
of your own personal experience
to understand kind of the nature
and extent of the social
problems that you face
in your community and its schools.
So the answer to how safe are our
schools is that schools are safer
and crime rates are declining.
That if you compare 1992 to
2014 we've had an 82% decline
in students experiencing
victimization at schools,
and that the percentage
of public schools
that reported students being bullied
at least once a week
decreased from 29% to 16%.
This is a graphic display of kind
of the victimization at school
between 1992 and 2013,
a clear decline.
The big takeaway on kind of
schools across the country is
that schools are safer
than they've ever been.
It's important to recognize that.
At the same time there's important
work that needs to be done.
Here are some examples.
25% of middle school students
experience bullying in 2012, 2013,
so that's one out of
four, that's a lot.
And this is actually the statistic
that is more concerning to me,
50% of those incidents were
not reported to an adult.
So you've got one out of four
kids who are experiencing bullying
and 50% of those kids did not report
it to an adult, and many of you
in your essays talk about why
things are not reported to adults.
And I think the primary culprit
and really this falls on adults is
that when you report it, they
didn't do something to take care
of the problem, that adults failed
you and that is something that we,
as adults, have to own up to.
The other is that you're afraid
that or hoping that it'll go away
and that if you report it it
will bring attention to the issue
and it'll only make matters worse.
And I want to say something
about bullying,
just to kind of give you some
insights, because a number of you
in your essays talk about bullying.
And one of the questions
that I think you ask yourselves
is why do bullies do this?
Many times in your essays you said
to the person who was bullying you,
why are you doing this to me?
And a number of you kind of
hit the nail right on the head,
that we know two things about
kids who bully other kids.
One is that they're being abused
at home or in their own lives,
they are victims of abuse.
The other is that they are doing
it to gain social status, they are,
if you kind of divide kind of the
social hierarchy into thirds they're
at the bottom of that middle third
and they're afraid of falling
into the lower tier, into the
bottom third of their peer group.
They're actually afraid of becoming
the kids who will be bullied.
And so what you see in both cases,
one, they're victims of abuse and,
two, they're scared kids.
And I know that bullies don't come
across as scared, but lots of kids,
and I'm going to get to
this, lots of kids who engage
in violent behavior are
doing so out of fear.
Even though they act tough and
they're big and bad and they seem
like they're not afraid of
anything, underneath that kind
of veneer is a great deal of fear.
Here's something else that's a
big concern to us in schools,
that in 2011-12 10% of public school
teachers reported being threatened
with injury by a student from their
school in the previous 12 months,
and that in the same year 6%
of public school teachers
reported being physically attacked
by a student from their school
in the previous 12 months.
This is a very serious statistic,
that we count on teachers,
teachers are kind of the
lynchpin in the whole system.
If one out of 10 has
been threatened and six
out of 100 have been attacked how do
we expect teachers to be effective
and comfortable and
engaging with their students?
So the takeaway from these
statistics are, number one,
schools are safer than they've
ever been but, number two,
there's a lot of work
that needs to be done.
What's the work that
needs to be done?
And this is a question that I
get all the time as the Director
of the Office of Safe and Healthy
Students I'm often asked what are
the biggest threats
to school safety?
And I want you to kind
of ask yourselves that
and if you have a good idea raise
your hand, take a moment to hear
from anyone who might be willing
to identify what they think are the
biggest threats to school safety.
Any of our authors want to take a
chance and take a guess on this,
or not a guess, what
is your opinion?
Because this is just my opinion.
Nice and loud.
Can you stand up, please?
[ Inaudible ]
>> David Esquith: Very
good, good answer.
Anyone else?
Yes, nice and loud, please,
so that everyone can hear it.
[ Inaudible ]
>> David Esquith: People lashing
out at others by using weapons.
Very good answer, and I
think that's certainly true.
What I'm looking for here are
kind of the underlying causes.
What are the underlying causes
and what are the biggest
threats to school safety?
One more, yes, nice
and loud, please?
[ Inaudible ]
>> David Esquith: Would
you like to come and work
for the Department of Education?
Because that is a great,
great answer and pretty much
where I'm going with this, as well.
So thank you.
Here's what I think are the
biggest threats to school safety
that we face based on what we know.
Loneliness, fear and hopelessness.
When you have students
who are terribly lonely,
who are terribly afraid and, in my
opinion, probably the most powerful
of these characteristics, when they
are feeling hopeless they are a risk
to themselves and to others.
And that in order for us to
kind of get at the behaviors,
kind of the violent behaviors, we
have to get at these experiences
that these students are having.
And so what happens when
students are lonely,
where are we seeing
this kind of manifest?
We're seeing it in gang involvement,
people are looking for connections,
they're looking for
those relationships.
We see it in abusive relationships,
this is a particularly
significant problem with young girls
who are coming up into middle
school and getting into high school
and they get involved in
abusive relationships.
And somehow they think
those abusive relationships
when we've studied kind
of what they're experiencing
they think that's the norm,
they think that being in an abusive
relationship is somehow normal.
They might be seeing it at home or
they don't have any other norms,
but they are lonely and
looking for that connection,
that personal connection.
We see it in violent extremism.
As I said, I've been doing a
lot of work around this lately
and you have young people
who are becoming radicalized,
they're sitting in front of
their - on their computer
and they are getting picked
up by these predators who are
out there looking to offer them
something that doesn't exist,
but it gives them a
connection with something.
And human trafficking is the
same thing, and when I talk
about human trafficking
what we're experiencing
in schools particularly are
young girls being recruited
into prostitution by gangs,
which is a significant problem
in virtually every
part of the country.
So these are some of
the kind of the traps
that people can fall
into if they are lonely.
Fear, many of you kind of talked
about some kind of concepts
and principles in school
psychology and you may be familiar
with this idea that when you
are afraid you experience kind
of one of two emotions.
You experience either fight
or flight, you're afraid
and your reaction is to get in a
kind of an aggressive mood to fight
with kind of the person or
persons who is scaring you,
or there's flight, you leave,
you run away, and those are kind
of the two basic responses to fear.
So what do we see in fight?
And this gets back to the point I
was making before about bullying.
You have bullying and cyber bullying
and you have school shootings.
What we know about so many active
shooter situations is that,
number one, it is kind of an
act of suicide and, number two,
these are individuals who have been
living with a great deal of kind
of fear and alienation
their entire lives.
And then there's flight,
we have runaways
and drug abuse and dropouts.
And the Department has
done a study of absenteeism
and it's kids avoiding school,
sometimes they avoid school
because they're afraid
to go to school
and losing out on their education.
So you've got kind of that
second characteristic.
And then third is hopelessness,
and as I said this I
just my personal opinion
but I think it is kind of the most
powerful and destructive emotion,
that if you have someone who
is feeling genuinely hopeless
and that is a kind of stark
reality they are prone to suicide
or drug abuse or again kind
of dropping out, just
kind of giving up.
Young people giving up on their
education is just kind of a shame
and a pity that with their
whole future in front
of them they don't see any
future and they drop out.
So how do we combat loneliness,
fear and hopelessness?
I have two girls, Sally and
Daisy, who are 10 years old.
And I think it was this year,
kind of the end of the year,
I was just curious and
I said to Sally, Sally,
who is your favorite teacher of
all the teachers that you've had
from kindergarten through
fourth grade?
And she responded like
that, she said Ms. Jones,
Ms. Jones is my favorite
teacher by far.
And I asked her why, what
was it about Ms. Jones?
And what she said was that Ms.
Jones believes in everyone,
which is really a very,
very profound statement.
I mean this idea of believing in
everyone, of a teacher believing
in everyone in that classroom, that
they all have something positive
to say, they all have a
contribution they could make.
And from the top of the school
roster down to the bottom
of it, that was Ms. Jones.
And Sally knew it and Sally
kind of falls, you know,
she's not at the top and
she's not at the bottom,
but she knew that Ms. Jones
believed in everyone in that class
and for her that was kind
of the highest compliment
you could make to a teacher.
So how do we do this?
There's a person who I admire,
and if any of you have a chance
to read any of his work or
follow anything he does,
called Brian Stevenson
[Assumed Spelling],
whose name is Brian Stevenson.
And one of the things that Brian
does, he's a lawyer so I'm going
to say a good thing
about a lawyer here, Dan.
And he defends people
who are on death row
and is a death penalty opponent
because statistics prove
that it's not a matter of kind of
whether it's the right thing to do,
the wrong thing to do, but
the system is so out of whack
that it disproportionately leads
people of African-American descent
and color to their
deaths disproportionately.
He said that one out of
every nine persons who is
on death row has been
exonerated, think about that.
And one of the things that
Brian says is that if one
out of every nine planes crashed how
many of us would get on an airplane?
So one of the things, so
the people have asked Brian,
because some of these
crimes are heinous and some
of these individuals just look
like they have absolutely there's
no socially redeeming quality
about any of these individuals.
And one of the things
that Brian says
and I think it's an
important lesson to kind of,
as you put this mosaic together,
is that each of us is more
than the worst thing we've ever
done and I think that that kind
of captures some of this idea
of believing in everyone.
I think the other thing that
has to happen, you know,
the Greeks had two sayings,
the Greeks which was a pretty good
civilization that lasted a long time
and served as the foundation
for so much of what we do today.
They had two kind of
idioms that they lived by.
One was everything in moderation,
which is really a very good idiom.
The other was know thyself, that
in order for us to find the good
and believe in everyone we
first have to really kind
of know ourselves and our own
prejudices and our own biases
and what pushes our buttons.
So that when we encounter someone
who is not necessarily a
highly desirable individual,
who may have a lot of challenges
that are manifesting themselves
in doing things that are wrong and
bad, we're able to kind of know,
kind of separate ourselves and know
ourselves from our ability to try
to promote what is good in them.
And so and I think this third
quality is what Sally was talking
about is that is if we can
see the strength in everyone,
that everyone has strengths.
We all have weaknesses,
everyone here has a weakness,
everyone here has flaws.
But when we look at an
individual and see their strengths
and see what is positive
about them and nurture it,
as opposed to seeing their
problem that we want to fix,
then we're on our way
towards helping
that person avoid loneliness,
fear and hopelessness.
And, finally, and this is really
kind of more directed to the adults,
that we have to build
trust with young people
and we have to keep that trust.
And so building that trust means
being there when we're needed
and keeping that trust means
kind of following up on our word,
that when a young person
comes to us and tells us
that they've been bullied
that we don't drop the ball
and that we follow-up and do as
much as we can to keep them safe,
but also kind of resolve
the bullying
in as positive a way as possible.
And so I want to conclude by just
kind of making this simple remark.
Number one, again, I'm just so
impressed and congratulate all
of you for everything that
you've done, and I hope that some
of the things that I've shared with
you today you kind of take back
to your communities to help kind
of see the good in everyone,
and as challenging as that may be,
and I think in the long run if all
of us do that we will see
a significant reduction
in the violence that we all face.
So thank you, all, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Dan Callister: As we
mentioned last night, our primary
and long-term founding sponsor
for the program is the Quade America
Foundation [Assumed Spelling],
Falsey Silton [Assumed
Spelling] is a very close friend
and Vice Chairman of the
Quade America foundation.
I'd like Falsey to
present to David two books.
One is for David and one is for
the new Secretary of Education,
containing the writings
of our students.
So if you'll do that,
Falsey, thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Falsey Silton: Thank you, David.
>> Dan Callister: Thanks, Falsey.
[ Applause ]
Okay, you weren't a lawyer,
somehow that was lodged in my mind,
but I think it was actually because
good lawyers, I hope, really,
really, really try to understand the
world that their clients are facing
and truly understand the
problems so they can be of help.
and I think that is one of
your greatest strengths, David,
just listening to you speak today
I think we could all understand how
much time you spend really
thinking about human nature
and what are the root causes of
the problems that we humans have
and that we visit on one another.
And so I just thought it was
a brilliant job you did today
and appreciate all the work you're
doing for all of us in trying
to keep our schools safe
and our children safe.
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.